Maps on mobile devices have changed the
world over the last few years they not
only provide a local map in your pocket
but also a map of the entire world down
to street level and even a 3d fly around
of many major cities in the maps for
Android developers course created by
Udacity and Google you'll start by
learning how to add maps to your Android
app and you'll progress to using the
street view API to build a virtual hike
all the way down the Grand Canyon learn
about the camera and how it's used to
project a map you'll learn about zooming
to different locations and changing the
camera tilt and direction you'll learn
about markers and how you can place them
on a map take this course to learn how
to transport your users from wherever
they are to wherever they want to go for
more information visit
udacity.com/google